that brings me to a question that i have
for you but it's more for an
experimentalist do you always need a
theory to interpret the data or can you
just interpret the data without a theory
so for example collecting astronomical
data we're assuming that we're at no
special place in the universe and that
the laws are pretty much the same
throughout time
so
can you interpret the data without a
theory can you even make sense of the
data without a theory i don't think so i
think you always have to have something
in the back of your mind
because
otherwise the data
is not telling you anything
you have to put it in in a context
so just to give you an example uh
when i was a postdoc
you know
astrophysical
journals
used to come in print it was not on the
internet and
so i went to the library
at the institute for advanced study at
princeton and i saw that
before the 1980s there were
photographs published in print
where you can see
giant arcs of light
surrounding clusters of galaxies and
people just ignored them
the data was there it was
it was printed
you know in images that were put on pa
in papers
and nobody asked anything about those
arcs why are there arcs you know like
lightning strikes between galaxies like
sparks almost
well they look like arcs and then then
in the 1980s the subject of
gravitational lensing because
and then people
explain those arcs as
focusing of light by the force of
gravity you know so you have a cluster
of galaxies that acts on light from a
background source behind it let's say a
galaxy sits far away behind the cluster
and then the light that comes from that
galaxy is being gravitationally bent
and focused at the observer and you end
up with what is called an einstein ring
einstein already thought that this could
happen in 1940
so you can get a giant arc
of a background source that is part of
sort of a ring of
light that comes from gravitational
lensing and once they realized that they
said oh that that's a good explanation
for those arcs
but the arcs existed in the literature
before
and people just didn't think about it in
that context so you can have data it's
just without
a sense of what the data may mean
you might actually not
not pay attention to it